open the subcommittee on House Bill
232fn
when this committee last met we were
discussing a number of items regarding
costs and such I will tell you that I've
had conversations with a number of
people since then but before I discussed
that is there anything in particular
from the last meeting or anything from
the emails that you have received
that you would like to comment on or ask
thank you Mr chairman um
I'm just I I would like to hear from the
New Hampshire
Municipal Association
um
just on I believe they sent out an email
we got some information and just expound
on that information looking at if they
see cost and I guess I'm looking to see
what there was something said about a
gap analysis if they could explain that
that would be very helpful to me
I'm aware please approach I'm aware of
two emails that we received
one from the admissible Association
regarding the city of Concord and
referencing uh OSHA 1400 and then one
from Roche
which you had reiterated some
information you received from one of
your constituent towns so those are the
only two emails that I know that I have
received that I passed on to everyone
so regarding the one from Concord is
that pretty much what you're talking
about the one that came through
yesterday
okay
okay good morning I'm Margaret burns
with the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and
um two two Communications I've I've had
I think with members of the committee
the first was after I after the last
work session I spoke with our board of
directors about House Bill 232 and
issues of cost as well as what they
would need to see to better understand
this issue and to potentially not be
opposed to the bill as we currently are
and one of the things that they
discussed was needing to see a more
comprehensive Gap analysis meaning a
more comprehensive assessment of the
difference between the currently
applicable Rules promulgated by the
Department of Labor and the rules that
are being proposed to be put in place
the 1910 rules and that so that was one
of the questions they had was how do we
know what we're going to in order to
assess what the impact will be and what
kind of additional compliance training
other costs we will incur if if the new
rules are implemented so that that's
where the Gap analysis discussion came
from
um I know that subsequently there was
also some written testimony from the
safety coordinator in the city of
Concord which I had forwarded on related
to concerns that they have about the
difference between current rules that
apply to them as well as what and what
would apply under the 1910 rules our
board of directors also expressed that
they would think it would be prudent for
there to be a study Commission on the
issue so that stakeholders who would be
affected by new rules would have a
chance to be part of that investigation
and research and then be part of a
discussion and recommendation of
potential future legislation and so that
was one of the other recommendations
that was made when we had that
discussion
I am aware that assistant commissioner
Ogden in his free time
on weekends
or had his staff go through the entire
1910 and compared it to what they're
doing now
um so I'll um
in a minute I'm going to call him up
about that but um
are there any other questions of Mark of
and I was just speaking with assistant
commissioner I did not know there had
been I have not seen that analysis don't
worry about it it's just thick and I
asked for a copy of it I said we should
have at least one copy
okay so we can see it and I believe it's
at least two reams of paper
obviously we don't have that copy but it
has been done so no harm no file that
you haven't seen it because quite
frankly I wasn't able to figure out how
to download it because it was so big on
my computer so large
did you guys I think it's been sent to
so thank you you have any questions
um yeah Municipal Association
thank you
assistant commissioner Ogden if you
foreign
sir um so you you your your folks did go
through yeah and we've spoken to a few
um someone from New Hampshire caution
we've spoken with Miss Burns as well
we'll be happy to send them a copy just
one thing and I apologize because
they've now heard this explanation and
they'll hear it again uh to be clear
what we have uh might be sufficient for
purposes of a gap analysis in the sense
of what it essentially does is it lays
out
um what OSHA has
if if there is something in New
Hampshire on point that is presented
right with the corresponding section
within OSHA so when you go through this
document and we'll send out directions
on how to collapse it expand it and all
of those things but essentially what the
document is doing is laying out what
OSHA has if there's something on point
in New Hampshire it presents that if
there's something not on point in New
Hampshire the document highlights that
fact you will see that there are a lot
of things that OSHA has that New
Hampshire has nothing on in terms of
explicitly stated standard where I would
point out that I am not sure if it's
sufficient for purposes of a gap
analysis for what the municipal
Association is looking for is it does
not do a side by if there are existing
standards and there is an OSHA standard
while it lays them out side by side it
does not have a corresponding analysis
of uh which is better which is costly or
you know all of those things so I just
highlight that fact to not disappoint
folks when they ultimate open it I just
again up front what it is doing is
laying those things outside by side but
it's not doing a critical eye when they
when they each have uh something on
point
we started the hearing and there were
questions from representative soucy
about this um the word gap or the
concept Gap analysis um I believe it was
brought up in the
email that we all received from the
municipal Association
um uh regarding Concord so we had Miss
Burns in the municipal Association come
up and and explain the situation
and then I asked uh assistant
commissioner Ogden to discuss some
things so that's where we are so chair
is yours sir
thank you and I apologize Interstate 89
was off
it was a real disaster but I'm here I
took my four-wheel drive which is
probably a good idea
um
I guess uh one of the things that I'd
like to uh
put out there the chairman and I had a
exchange of of thoughts over the last uh
couple days and um
I was I was on the verge of preparing an
amendment that would have
um uh extended the
um the effective date out until uh
summer of 2024.
uh that seemed like it would resolve
some of the anxieties that folks were
experiencing
um and then some of the communications
that we received were looking for
additional uh
you know Gap analysis and and such which
frankly
um you know we've we've done a good
point well actually I use the term we
very Loosely um the department did a
good job of doing a comparison of the um
the OSHA standards and the department of
labor standards
um that those have not been widely
distributed uh part of the difficulty is
that the file that was created was a
rather immense
um but um
certainly that those can be shared with
interested parties so that uh that
analysis can be undertaken by others
um
what uh the chairman and myself
uh were thinking was instead of Simply
pushing back the uh
uh
the effective date perhaps it would be
more effective to retain the bill
um when you retain the bill you can
continue working on it so if essentially
we would retain it and I did some
exploring and the the speaker's office
some committees working on retained
bills during the session but that's
mainly you know committees like
education Science and Technology the
ones that have huge workloads they don't
want them putting their workloads aside
to work on something else the labor
committee has the luxury of not having a
huge workload in fact this year it's
actually lighter than usual so I think
we would have the ability to um
to go go to work on it and continue
working on it and do some of the things
that perhaps the study committee was
unable to get to
um but I I will say that uh
I'll speak for myself alone I'm I remain
very committed to getting these OSHA
standards
um uh brought into the public sector I
think it's critical
um I understand that folks want to know
exactly what it's going to mean
um but I I firmly believe that this is
something we need to do
um but I'm willing to take the time to
work with the stakeholders to uh
help them understand exactly what the uh
what it's going to mean to bring these
standards into play
so effectively what retaining the bill
would do is it would give us time to
start working now continue working
um
uh
I think we could even work during the
summer
we ran into some difficulty last year
the speaker indicated that he did not
want Study committees to be working
during July and August which was
a real problem for us but at any rate we
can work through the spring
through as much of the summer as we can
into the fall and essentially to retain
committees retained bills are generally
voted on on the first session day in
January
um so it gives us a good chunk of time
and frankly what would end up happening
is what that bill would be if if the
bill passes the house
and passes the Senate and gets signed by
the governor
um that would take place in the summer
of 2024 which is exactly when I was
going to put the I was going to suggest
we put the effective date to so we get
more time to work
um more time to get comfortable with the
idea
um but we um I mean we don't lose any
time
um over what we would have done so
um I I throw that out to the
subcommittee to get your thoughts on
doing this
thoughts
thank you Mr chairman I think it's a
great idea to continue working with the
department and stakeholders
to ease some of the nerves that we've
come across thank you
and I'll say the same thing
um I think it's a great idea and
it'll give everybody more time to
realize what is actually going to happen
and I do have one question if I may to
Mr Ogden
if you know the answer that's fine if
do we really feel do you feel that
we're that far off from safety standards
to what Brian wants to bring in is the
OSHA standard and just in general I mean
I can tell you I worked on the fire
department for 29 years
um
we didn't have the OSHA standards but
everything that we needed I mean and I
heard people discuss this uh earlier
about you know some of these smaller
towns may not have the equipment if they
have to go down into a hole
um you know tripods and all this stuff
and I can I could see that some smaller
towns may not have that but in your
opinion we
do you feel that we're really that far
off from Meeting those OSHA standards
it's tough to say but what I would say
is I certainly think that there are
probably pockets of places how
widespread those pockets are I'm I'm not
sure but I'm certain that there are
pockets of places that might be far off
I think it was referenced earlier the
fact that because New Hampshire does not
have explicitly stated standards does
not mean that there is no standards
because again individuals be looking at
the general duty Clause why I bring that
up is there could be certain employers
public employers who whether they don't
have compliance staff on hand whether
they don't have industry experts you
know accessible they might not know
where to look for such industry
standards or where to you know go and
try and find what they should be doing
and I think those are the instances in
which you might be in certain instances
far off from what OSHA would require so
I think it's possible I know that's
probably not the most satisfying answer
but I think that it is possible that
there are instances in which what is
happening might be uh might be a ways
off
and I think is is this Gap analysis
takes place it's going to be important
to keep in mind what you're just saying
that uh the department often looks to
the OSHA standards when New Hampshire
lacks a standard we've
discussed the difficulty that that
places on employers that you know
they're looking at the OSHA standards
but the department might look to the
OSHA standards when there's something
that appears to be unsafe and we don't
have a standard so
um
basically we would be the Gap we would
be filling is the gap between what the
employers can see now and what they
might be actually expected to
um comply with now without necessarily
being able to know it is that fair
I I think that that's fair and one thing
I would I guess uh preface before we
provide this document to folks it's a
discussion that we did have certainly in
the context of the study committee over
the summer is when you look at what is
not there it it can be quite jarring
because you will see all of these
instances in which New Hampshire does
not have anything out there specifically
or explicitly stating what the standards
are but to your point representative
Sullivan we would look to the general
duty Clause again use the example of
electricity there's different areas out
there that New Hampshire does not have
explicitly stated standard that does not
mean that it's a complete free-for-all
it does mean that we don't have
explicitly stated standard in lab 1400
or in two RSA 277 so instead we would be
looking at what provides for General the
employer having met the general duty
which might be us looking to OSHA it
might be us looking to building codes it
might be us looking to generous
generally industry accepted standards
but I do highlight that is when you see
what's not there there is a lot
and I guess I've been saying all along
that that's that's why we really need
these OSHA standards so that everyone
can look to the standards and everyone
can see what the expectations are they
don't have to wait until an inspector
says that's not safe and I'm going to
you know reference something that's not
in the uh the rules or not in the
statutes
um to to back me up so
um
oh I'll leave it at that but um
any any other thoughts on uh this path
please
I I'm fine um working through the summer
working on the study committee as long
as we need to to get this right and
hopefully get it to pass
um if that's the right decision
but my concern I'm going to bring back
is with the dates because if we move
this out to next January
School the the schools will already have
their budgets ready so if this is going
to become a cost that the schools are
going to have to incur to become
compliant although I'm feeling a little
bit more comfortable about that after
speaking with a couple of school
districts
um we would need to have this
information out to them by the fall of
2023 so that they can get it into the
next budget cycle
I think we're in the right time frame
for the municipalities to get it into
their budget cycle which would be voted
on in March and then there's no reason
why we can't continue having this
discussion as we go forward
um the the bill will be voted on
um if it comes out of the committee
um in January so we've got time to
figure out exactly what the implications
of the effective date would be so
um
it sounds like we've got a Way Forward
at least
for the subcommittee
oh may I please
be um
one of my initial
requests of Representative Sullivan was
a
um a commission and I wanted to
specifically outline I wanted one person
from fire one police one Municipal City
one Municipal Town someone from one of
the counties that represents you know
the nursing homes the Corrections
Department all those things so we get
these people that each one of these
individuals would break down their
portion of 1910 and how it would apply
to them Brian Appley explained to me
that you're right it's very difficult to
get a commission by the time you appoint
people you can't get a senator to do it
you're going to find a couple reps to do
it
uh it it may take you four months just
to get people in place it's best to just
retain it where you can kind of do the
same thing
because we're going to rely the
municipal Association to get us the
people that we want them to get for us
right so um and in fact that's so we'll
we'll we can we can accomplish the same
thing now I did also have a conversation
with the um assistant commissioner and
the commissioner on this
and because I started questioning some
of the things that are in 1910 I spoke
with the we uh the fire chief of Bedford
reached out to Brian and I and we have
spoken to him
yeah he started bringing up things
um which you know I I frankly had no
knowledge of
two in two out as a firefighter you
would know that you know two guys are
going in there needs to be at least two
guys outside making sure something
happened to them and what have you and
then I started reading these things
about all the reporting
there has to be a list written all the
time of who was doing what and where and
who was in the hole who was not all
these different things
um that
that leads me to wonder
are there things in 1910
that because we all know OSHA you know
great laudable uh organization and when
it was started and why it was started
and
the safety you know with the Brian as
you know someone was killed uh at Lowe's
um in Laconia this week
um when Lumber fell on him so accidents
do happen and and that was private
versus Municipal but it could it could
happen anytime
so long story short there are things
that could neither be done but are there
things in 1910 that are really
typical government useless that don't do
anything that no one's going to ever
check that the labor Department's not
even going to look at that is going to
cause
um
an undue cost for no benefit and and in
my email to you as I wrote don't get
into the argument of cost versus safety
because it's a losing argument yeah um
um
the
but there are when I started getting
these this feedback from certain people
as to well we're doing this but if we do
this it's going to cost a lot more so my
conversation with the commissioner is
this commissioner are in 1910 are there
things that are covered elsewhere are
there things that really
um we don't have to
we don't feel a really appropriate
to do and that's where you know I'm
I told you that I cannot look at you in
the eye and everybody else and say I
want to pass this bill if I don't know
all the different things I can't hear
from everybody so that's where I'm
coming from this regarding the budgets
we would have our
retained report out I believe the rule
is going to be November 1st probably
that's the the we have to have that
prepared I don't know that the retained
bill has a report necessarily
we would have to finish working on the
bill and then we'll be voted on in
January but I think it needs to be
I think that work in the retained bills
does need to be completed right around
November we can double check that but
yeah but it's right in there because as
I was talking with the fire chief he has
a problem with some of these things he's
like gee well I really don't want to be
locked down as a fire as a fire chief
um to the two and two because I show up
to a fire there's only three of us
and I really need two guys to go in what
am I going to do I'm going to allow one
in you know there are certain things
that happen in real life versus what's
on a piece of paper and that's all I
want to get to the bottom of
and I guess what uh what I'd like to
hear uh what I'd like to do is develop a
list of all those folks that we want to
be reaching out to
um to involve
um uh
in the process going forward between now
and when uh the bill is uh
um ready to go
um so I'd be happy to hear from folks
who are in the audience who um
would like to be involved with this
process
um
please
you don't have any uh pin cards so they
have to identify yourself for us
hey good morning my name is David Ross
and I'm the administrator of
Hillsborough County nursing home I
applaud the committee's thoughtful
consideration today to retain this bill
to allow opportunity for more input and
discussion about how to properly
Implement these changes I would be happy
to participate in in this discussion
um and in this work group to be able to
help
strategize because we do see that this
could potentially have significant
impact on our nursing home operations
specifically
um The Gap analysis the the department
has prepared will be helpful for us to
review but it also will require us to do
a facility specific Gap analysis to be
able to take a look at where does our
practice deviate from these new
standards and discuss an implementation
plan specifically
much as you shared the Bedford fire
chief shared the same so
um I think that that's a great approach
I applaud your thoughtful consideration
here and would love to participate great
and if you could leave some contact
information that'd be great happy to
I'll leave that with uh Kate Horgan
who'll get that over to you okay thank
you thank you
yes sir
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
um
does anything stand out
on first glance that you would be
concerned about
um there was so much to go through
um I think what we have to really go
through is the bloodborne pathogen
standards specifically
um hazardous materials lockout tag out
all of those components that we have
elements of those
um in place at our facility I'm just not
confident that we have full compliance
with each of those standards so it
really does require such an in-depth
review the 1910 standard is over 2200
pages so there's so much information and
detail that's included in there it
really warrants a very substantial Deep
dive
the standard what standards do you
follow now just general practice or just
business industry or whatever that's
correct yeah that's correct yeah thank
you
thank you
there you go thank you for giving me
this opportunity
um I think it's a great idea I believe
that it will give the committee the
opportunity to hear from voices that
they were unable to hear from over the
summer with the commission committee
that
um came up this bill came out of I would
respectfully request that some employees
public employees from some of the
sectors that where employers will be
represented
I mean I'm a union guy I'm all in
I'm sorry can you introduce yourself for
me certainly I'm sorry uh my name is
Susie Nord and I work for the National
Council for occupational safety and
health
anyone else want to weigh in
thank you
and benefits for the Department of
administrative Services over the state
um
and all of the agencies of the state so
we would be rolling down two weeks
the fact industries that the state
employees
and our budget collect a little bit
different it sounds like better
municipalities so I just want to be
sensitive to that too if you all know
the state budget services
okay
yep
um and uh
is is there anyone other than yourself
that might uh be a likely candidate to
um
it's so like we would want to talk with
the New Hampshire hospital
um
correction
okay yeah I would definitely want to
get their perspectives too and that
would probably include someone today
okay
and and
as we move forward we'll probably have
to figure out how much of the work
your department will do with the other
departments and how much work will
actually be done by the subcommittee
here so we'll sort that out because it
might be more time that the subcommittee
can actually devote
um and uh but basically you can bring
some reports to the subcommittee as to
what you've uh uncovered and the I agree
with the comment about can't be funny
I've been arguing to Trump see totally
agree with that oh I just want to think
about some of the resources that you
variation of Readiness in something that
is often Republic
so we would want to make sure we had
those fun things the funding available
to start them I don't know where that is
I know it's not on my radar so I don't
have a department of administrative
services
I didn't really answer yeah
okay yeah that's good and my
understanding is the budget is going to
have enough money for everything
everything
so
thank you
no question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Whitman again um for being here with us
um could you also put a cost analysis as
well with some of those
um upgrades that you would probably need
in the assessment of the overall the Gap
analysis yes
yeah a realistic cost from what you have
now because
um a follow-up Mr you can just keep
going yeah
um we spoke last time about
um when you got when D.O.T is working on
Bridges they follow industry standards
how far off are those industry standards
from the 1910. so if they already have
um policies procedures in place that
almost mirror those would that be a
large
okay you know undertaking for them to do
that or just I'm which I'm just doing
the bridge thing because you know we all
see those happening
okay stuff like that and we'll keep the
subcommittee in the loop too as what
we're learning yes thank you thank you
yeah and I guess one of the please
um while you're coming up one of the
other things that keeps coming back to
me in our many conversations with the
Deputy Commissioner of Labor is uh the
manner in which that the department
works is not um we're looking for
violations so that we can rake in the
the fines
um the way the department works is when
we um when we find a violation we work
with the employer to resolve it
um and if it if in some cases that means
um
it's not the the resolution is going to
cost a few bucks that's not in the
current budget and we're going to work
with you to come up with an interim
resolution
um that keeps folks safe but operates
within the current budget uh and and
they they do that now with the current
uh standards so it's there's
I'm confident they will continue
operating the same way we're simply
giving a more detailed set of standards
for everyone to be aware of so identify
yourself please
good morning everyone I'm Colin Tiernan
I'm here with the state employees
Association and I think this is a
valiant effort and we'd love to support
thank you
um and and
um I think the the sea would be a a good
partner to plot provide those employee
perspectives so uh love to help
facilitate um numerous different
departments you got it thank you
Mr chairman yes please just since this
gentleman has
come up to speak
in particular obviously you've had
conversations about this bill you've had
conversations about 1910. could you give
me one or two specific hot points that
your group or or you and individually
um have concerned with or are
extremely happy with just give us an
idea of where you're coming from
I'd say the workers at the Department of
Transportation and Department of
Corrections I definitely would love to
pull them in I don't have any specific
heartaches or or or
um or examples but I think like in
general I think those are two
departments that I would love to help
are there others who would like to uh
um well I think what we'll be doing is
uh developing lists of folks that we
want to rope in and uh participate and I
think we've got a good start here
um but
um
this is work that I think we would have
liked to have done with the study
committee
but unfortunately that that started too
late which is why I did uh press
uh chairman infantine that uh
there are
things that slow study committees and
commissions down
um keeping this is a retained Bill the
labor committee owns it the labor
committee keeps it the labor committee
remains responsible for it we don't have
to find a senator to play along
um we uh great respect for the Senate
but we we can continue working without
having to uh deal with the uh the
impediments that our legislative process
often creates so
um looking forward to it
any other thoughts before we
I'd be delighted to hear a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I move that the
subcommittee adopts
retained status for this bill
and I'll second that motion okay
um and we've got four committee members
and uh
um I would I guess I'll just do a roll
call vote
representative Holcomb
yes representative Susie representative
avalani yes and representative Sullivan
votes yes as well so basically we have a
unanimous vote to uh and just to be
clear
um representative inventine is not uh
part of the subcommittee uh we
appreciate him being here and um on the
phone I told him that we would hope that
he would be the Perpetual fifth member
um and continue to uh uh provide his uh
thoughts and input as we move forward
um because we're pretty much evenly
divided in the house we've got evenly
divided committees and subcommittees um
but um I think we will have a technical
five member group moving forward
um so
um
I will fill out the necessary paperwork
and will bring us back to the committee
I believe on the 16th correct
yes okay
perfect
so thank you very much folks and I guess
in 15 minutes the other subcommittee
hold on
um
representative love
and representative Sullivan you're
filling in for representative McKenzie
today who cannot be here
oh Associated okay and my apologies
yep
okay I want to open the uh
the
meeting for um House Bill 82 FN uh
it's an act relative to employment
protection with participants in
therapeutic cannabis program and uh
let's go around and representative
Sullivan uh myself representative love
representative soucy and representative
cologne is am I pronouncing your last
okay
anyway
um we've we've had some discussion on it
and uh
does does anybody have uh any further
ideas that uh that they've thought of
I think one of one of the things that um
I think is is
most uh telling for me is the court case
um
knowing that the courts have already
pretty much determined that you have to
um
that firing somebody for
the therapeutic cannabis use
um is is not allowed but
not having the law to actually you know
guide that
concept I really think it's it becomes
more critical that we we put something
together here that that works because uh
um someone shouldn't have to make their
way through the court system in order to
um you have the rights preserved so I I
it just seems critical that we we do put
something in place here
we did just receive an email that looks
like it shows the laws in the different
states so I have not had a chance to
review that I'm just scanning it now
um
you know
I still am one who
has an issue with cannabis use in the
workplace and I also have an issue with
the fact that we would be restricting
employers from how they feel
um they need to manage their their staff
and their business
so
I'm hesitant on
the direction of this one
I know for myself
um
I have concerns about the the liability
if an accident happens uh in a in a
workplace
um you know the uh I I know of a case a
long time ago where it's going to be 30
years ago where a man lost and I and
when he uh went to the hospital
in a cigarette pack he had a couple
joints in the cigarette pack in the
north sarit and uh the insurance company
denied coverage and I don't want any
um
any employer to be on the hook for that
um you know I we've
passing this prior prior to to fixing
the liability laws for it would be a
mistake
um
you know would you have to get into the
insurance coverage end of it and uh you
know there's there's unintended
consequences I guess is uh is my problem
with this and uh you know not not that I
I don't like the idea of the law
but um to to take um taking employers
rights away
like Roche said you know the the rights
how they're going to conduct their
business and the liability
um I think this is uh this bill is a
little premature until we until we fix
representative Mr chairman
I'm going to look at it from a different
perspective
um
I think
I hear everybody's concerns
but I also feel that
there is probably use of opioids
um in the workplace
um today
um which somebody probably really needs
to be using them
and they could be using them at work
they could be using them when they're
driving a forklift and we don't know
that at this point
um
and again I think with the I think the
misconception here with the cannabis use
and I said this last week
I don't believe for one second that
people that are on the therapeutic
cannabis
um
looking to
and I'll use this Loosely be Stoners
because I don't think that's what they
really want I think they're looking for
some relief
um
from the medical issues that they may
have trying to get outside of the realm
of using opioids and I think if we look
around
every state around us
is legalizing marijuana
we have a bill here
um that we'll see where that goes but
it's being legalized and the one thing
that I don't see
from around all these other states
um
people talked about when Colorado First
legalized marijuana and the problems
they were having well
I don't see on the news every night any
issues with
um other states talking about issues
that they're experiencing with cannabis
use
so I think the people that are in this
therapeutic cannabis program
I'm going to say that I believe that
fact that they probably use it
um at night before they go to bed to
help them sleep to help them take away
it's guaranteed that if they would be
tested the next morning they would have
some sort of it would be in the system
but it does not
for one second mean that those people
are impaired it's kind of like alcohol
alcohol will go through your system but
I think representative a former
representative kenrik explained it very
well the way that cannabis
um it goes into the body and is you know
goes through the body slower and that's
why you know you get the positive test a
lot of times so I
I'm all on board with trying to get
something that we can use here to help
these folks out
um I don't want to shut them out because
I truly believe that they want to get
back into the workforce
um I think there was some information
that was brought forward to us that's
helpful I think we look at what other
states are doing but I do truly believe
that there is a way to do this I just
don't have the answer right now today
but
um
I truly do believe that we can do this
without it really being a big issue so
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative you know
there's been a lot of uh talk about
cavouts which different occupations and
stuff and uh you know that that might be
an Avenue we might want to go down and
um you know uh you know the safety
concerns and what have you
um you know
it's uh you know it'll require some work
because I've done a lot more a lot more
time than what we have here but um
you know it's it's something we we could
look at but once again those uh you know
the the insurance and the but the
liability end of it um you know
um I've got a lot of concerns there
and um you know I don't I don't want to
see somebody who's uh taking a second
mortgage out on their home to put a
business together only to to lose it if
there's an industrial accident and uh
find out that they're not covered
because their employees on the the
Cannabis um
card system you know a program we've got
to look into that I think it's a great
build a great idea but I think it's
representative thank you I I think there
I think there's a combination of a lot
of facts here and if anyone has not read
the rules
um I really recommend they do
um the
what you have to do
to in order to
um
become employed with someone and to be
able to use therapeutic cannabis
there needs to be a sign off by the
employer
there are a number of things you cannot
do by rule
driving Vehicles using Machinery doing
all these things
um
so
um being an insurance guy I respect what
you're saying
but I don't know as if because the
employer has the ability prior to
signing off
to present that to their insurance
carrier for approval or not this is what
this person is going to do and and we we
have it happens all the time in my
business or someone says I want to hire
somebody but they had a DWI three years
ago am I going to be able to allow them
to drive a service ban some insurance
carriers say yes some say no we submit
it to them and if they give it a thumbs
up then they can drive if not they can't
so
um you know the owner has that ability
the
I'm overly concerned with some of the
things that are being brought forth in
this committee we have two bills if you
think about it out of 13 bills we have
two
where
the bill tries to
fired
for a certain Behavior
and I'm very cautious about that
slippery slope
employers can it's an at-will state
you look at me funny someday and I don't
like it and I can let you go some people
have a real hard time with that they
don't like that at all so you're right
guys we have to come in between the
Middle here
um
but this bill says you cannot be fired
just because you have a positive test
the test doesn't mean that you're
intoxicated with THC
it just says you can't be fired for a
positive test now
why would anyone test someone
they know
is on therapeutic marijuana because they
I don't know why they would bother they
know what their results going to be
um
then you look at the amount of people
that are employed in the state of New
Hampshire and I don't really want to
take away 4 000 people's jobs you know I
wouldn't want them to be released and
I'm glad 4 000 people are
um employed in using therapeutic
marijuana so I I think
you have to look at all of the different
things that are there the employer makes
a decision you know and and what I just
said about I'm very worried about a
slippery slope about
letting people go and legislature
starting to mandate when employers can
and cannot let someone go
but
um this one seems to be a little more
voluntary
they have to sign off on this
they don't have to
and I I want to see if I can get someone
to come up and ask some questions
afterwards if I could they don't have to
sign that letter
the employer
now you say sorry you know don't
I'm not going to agree to it and then so
um
you know that we're unlike this other
other bills where it says well you can't
let someone go because of X I can't
think of an example right now so I can't
think of an analogy but
um
you know the employer agreed to it can
the employer at one point say and I
think these are some of the questions I
have so I I hire because I because what
representative Souci says is very
accurate we have a former state
representative who's a friend of mine
he was a paratrooper in the military
and he hurt his back
uh in in the military from jump out of
planes and they had this guy so high on
opioids
and he was going to die he came home one
day and told his wife I'm gonna die
if I keep doing this and he went cold
turkey off the opioids and and started
smoking marijuana I think he's one of
the first people to get the uh the
medical card
and he's very happy right now and he's
so much better off than when I first met
the man
and so I have to look at those things
this saved this guy's life
and he works
um at a at a place he's a baker uh and
uh his employer so I I have to look at
some of the positives of this I will
also be a real realistic about politics
and being what it is
because we can all make our own
decisions here in the committee which is
fine but as I told representative
Sullivan on the phone yesterday
we had an overwhelming majority of
people in the house a significant
majority I don't say overwhelming a
significant majority allow the state
to have
uh recreational marijuana last week
okay I was not one of them
um
if this committee comes out
this is one of my concerns as the
chairman if this committee comes out and
this thing is an Ito
I can pretty much guarantee you
someone's going to stand up on the house
floor
and they're going to challenge it and
there's probably enough votes to
override what this committee would want
to do if this committee comes out with a
negative report based on what happened
um with the last uh vote in the house
so my thought process is is maybe this
is more
being too much of a politician in me but
I'd rather figure out what the bill is
going to be we better make it really
good because if it's not and you don't
like it and it passes then you're
dealing with that so just something to
keep in the back your mind and I'll shut
up because I'm not on this committee I
just don't but I would like to ask a
thank you and thank you for what you're
saying
um with all due respect I would like to
correct one thing the bill doesn't Focus
just on the firing it actually it also
has in there that an employer cannot
hire if somebody tests positive
um and I think that's a piece that's
very risky because they don't know
anything about this person so they're
they're hiring on good faith through an
interview or process and a testing
process and I
hear what you're saying as far as the
votes as well I think that piece the
very least needs to be removed they
should be able to have be free to make a
decision on hiring practices and not
have this hanging over their head as a
potential discrimination lawsuit that
they were chosen not to be hired because
they tested positive
um so from that perspective and you know
I'd like to share what I witnessed on
Monday now I personally
have never used cannabis so I can't say
for certain what I saw is actually what
I saw but I was sitting at the lights
coming off of Route 89 and next to me in
the vehicle was a person smoking what
appeared to me as a joint and she's like
I didn't look like a Marlboro it did not
it did not it had a distinct look to it
so it could have been a homemade
cigarette so I'll give that but it
certainly looked like a joint that she
was smoking while she was sitting at the
lights and I immediately thought of this
saying and the testimony that we heard
about people know that they're not
supposed to do this and if she was on
her lunch break or if she was on her way
to work you know it begs the question
and you know it also
justifies the concern of our Police
Department when they say you know this
is a problem because we cannot test the
level of
um intoxic
intoxication from
um
um I
didn't share this last week but uh just
took this out of my wallet it is in New
Hampshire cannabis registry card
um
the reason I'm bringing it up today is
because
I'll also say that I
tried the Cannabis exactly once it
didn't
agree with me
um I won't go into details and I'm
frankly not going to say why I was using
it but I do have the card and the reason
I bring it up is because one of the
pieces of Education that I got in
considering and deciding to go that
direction is that
the purpose is not to be intoxicated
the purpose is to use
just enough to deal with the symptoms
that you're trying to address
and it's different from that person
who's in the car who uh smoking a joint
that person is smoking a joint for the
sole purpose of becoming intoxicated
um
the
therapeutic cannabis
serves a much different purpose it is
there it it is being used to deal with
symptoms not to create intoxication
so um and and basically one of the
people I talked to when I was
considering This was
um Dr canurk
um former representative knurk and you
know he explained very carefully to me
that um
the the trick is to get just enough to
deal with your um symptoms and there's
no intention of being intoxicated so I
think I think that needs to be very
clear to us if someone is has got the
card they're being counseled to uh to
use it in that manner so um and that's
that's different
um so I I do want to put a bill forward
frankly I'm comfortable with the amended
version that we had
um uh last time we met but I'm also open
to modifications of that
um if the subcommittee or some of the
folks who are here can suggest
modifications to it that would make it
uh more effective more palatable
um I'm good with that but I believe uh
um I guess I'm I'm going to be pragmatic
like uh chairman infantein as being
um
something where we're going to end up
with something let's make it as good as
we can so
um but let's separate the uh
recreational use of cannabis from the
therapeutic use of cannabis they're two
different things and serve two very
one of my problems would be how
um how do we separate it there
representative Susie was talking uh he's
you know talking how you know most of
these people will certainly just use
them to therapy therapeutic use and and
I'm sure you know that that there are
certainly people with those with those
cards that are abusing it too
um how do we separate them uh you know
what what kind of language can we put in
that separate
you know how can we allow an employer to
say look at you know you're going
overboard with this
um I I think the language of the bill is
clear
um if someone is impaired
um at work
because they're drinking because they're
using opioids or because they're using
um cannabis to the point of becoming
impaired you can be fired for that
nothing in this section shall be
construed to require an employer to
allow being impaired by cannabis
products while at work
so basically if the employee is impaired
that's
um
grounds for uh
action on the part of the employer
but she can't prove it
you know there's no tests that that it
says whether I smoked a joint a week and
a half ago or 20 minutes ago
um you know in in my judgment he was
impaired won't stand up in court
you know it won't stand up before the
labor board
um
you know this is the the hurdle we have
they think think that was put in there
to Simply to to clearly answer that
issue if a person is impaired that's not
okay
um and um I did Labor Relations long
enough that I represented folks that
were impaired in various ways and when
they were there are consequences often
there was counseling involved
um but basically being impaired at work
um
is not okay and not allowed under this
bill
I still can't understand how a case like
that would stand up in
any Labor Board hearing or a court of
law uh because you can't prove like I
said whether I smoke that joint a week
and a half ago about 20 minutes ago
um you know
that in my opinion wouldn't for from
somebody who's uh
who's not an alcohol and drug counselor
for instance uh you know as a witness
wouldn't hold up
um you know in in litigation
let me play it out is what I would have
experienced as a labor rep representing
an employee who
um was impaired at work or allegedly
imperative work
um if that employee was disciplined or
terminated because of that
um a grievance would be filed
that grievance would go through the
process of the various administrative
levels would go to the school board and
if the grievance was denied at all those
various levels would end up before an
arbitrator
that arbitrator would have a hearing and
at that hearing the person who observed
the impairment would be questioned in
detail as to what they observed
and
basically arbitrators operate by the
sniff test if it's
if it smells like bologna it's probably
bologna and so essentially they're going
to go in The credibility of uh the uh
the employee versus The credibility of
the supervisor and
I had lots of experiences where
arbitrators sided with the employer
because they believed that the employee
was indeed doing what the employer
alleged so it is not impossible to uh to
deal with something like this in fact if
if it's not a union environment it's
much easier because basically they're
the only recourse there is to the courts
um and um
the judge would do the same thing
um question very carefully what the
person observed what they saw what they
witnessed and reach a conclusion
um and and basically under this law the
judge would be looking over the
arbitrator would be looking
um to say that just because you've got a
card doesn't mean you can be impaired at
work this says very specifically it is
not allowed to be impaired at work so um
I think this uh this bill does it it in
in and basically with regard to the
hiring situation
it says no employer shall deny
employment terminate or take
disciplinary action solely because
if you decide to um not hire somebody
for any you know there when you do an
interview
you learn a lot about that uh potential
employee
and you could choose any one of a dozen
other factors that cause you to choose
not to hire that individual just because
the person has a therapeutic cannabis
card doesn't mean you have to hire them
it simply means you can't decide not to
hire them solely because they've got the
card
so you don't say that at all what's that
yeah
it doesn't say you can't hire anything
doesn't have a card
it's it's only because the individual is
a qualifying patient of the New
Hampshire therapeutic cannabis program
that's the card okay I apologize I was
reading something else I I misspoke
sorry Brian okay I apologize it's okay
um so so basically it's only because
they've got the card or solely because
of a positive drug test but but
basically you can terminate the employee
for a dozen other reasons you can choose
not to hire the employee for a dozen
other reasons it's just you cannot base
that decision solely on those two
factors
representative Susie okay thank you Mr
chairman
I think we need to understand as well
that
these committees are policy committees
and it's our job to put together
um legislation that is good legislation
and we are not going to decide and we
can't decide as to what a judge may
think or an arbitrator may think
um
it's I just it's
up to us to put the legislation forward
and I agree with what representative
Sullivan said I think this is pretty
clear that they're saying that
impairment is not allowed at the
workplace
um so as a policy committee we've moved
the policy forward it's not our job to
worry about it is our job to look at
what um
the results could be but at the end of
the day we can't decide for a judge or
an arbitrator mediator whatever what
they're going to do and how they're
going to decide something but I think I
like the bill I mean I'd be open to
um modification I know there's going to
be exemptions I mean right off the bat I
mean I can look at jobs like the fire
department police CDL Drivers those I
mean obviously those are not going to
work under this bill but
I'm in favor of moving something forward
so thank you Mr chairman
who uh my my only thing with moving
something forward uh you know we're
putting put a lot of time into this so
far and there's going to be a lot more
um we don't want to just hand it to the
Senate and have them kill it uh you know
my time all our time is more valuable
than that
representative cologne thank you
um by May with representative Sullivan's
comments regarding hiring
um it's been my practice that when
somebody in a hiring process when
somebody is set for a drug screening
test it is done with a job offer here is
your job offer and the job officer
office offer is contingent upon passing
a drug screen
so if the drug screen happens and they
do come back positive with cannabis and
then the job offer is retracted and it
can be said that the offer was retracted
because of that so I don't believe that
we should be having
the Restriction in here for an employer
not being able to hire somebody
because they have no they're going on
good faith they have no experience with
this person to be able to say what type
of a worker they are how they manage
their cannabis card
um you know and in respect to you're
you're talking about people don't get a
cannabis card so that they could overuse
and they they can get intoxicated the
same could be argued with opioids you
know they they go on these they're not
supposed to be getting intoxicated
they're only supposed to be using it to
manage their pain that they get addicted
and they have overuse and I can see that
happening but to restrict an employer
from having to pull back a job or
continue forward with a job offer that
was contingent on passing a drug
screening I think is this is misplaced
in this bill
and I don't think it has it we we just
should not be getting involved in in the
I would just like to think I'd just like
to ask some questions of
um
I'm sorry sir I don't I don't remember
your name the gentleman the blue shirt
with the beard
distinguished gentleman Mr Holt Michael
are you are you um okay with this Mr
chairman
absolutely sure more information we can
so a couple things here and I gotta tell
you with legislation and my job I I have
not and you know we're not really being
on this committee
I'm sitting here because I think it's
important as a chairman to do so but
um I I am
I read it once and now I'm reading it
more specifically
some of the confusion if I were sitting
there behind you listening to this I
would think you're comparing a lot of
apples and oranges
am I accurate that you think some of the
conversation you're hearing is not
you don't have to answer that I know
what you're thinking
um sorry I didn't want to probably put
you in the spot so because I'm because
I'm looking at this I'm reading these
things
so there seems to be two issues that I
hear Number One releasing someone solely
because they have
a positive test
and hiring someone
and I look at then the prohibitions and
limitations of therapeutic use of
cannabis 126 X3
but before we get into this let's just
take a real life situation
okay because obviously this has happened
because the chart you showed me showed
there's over 4 000 people employed in
the state of New Hampshire someone's
provided me I'm not sure who that was me
okay provided there were approximately
four thousand people right now employed
in the state of New Hampshire
um and and others who had been employed
who are no longer employed for any
number of probably reasons right they
retired or just whatever
so we have two different situations okay
I have a person who works for me
and then they get they get they come
down with crohn's disease and that's one
of the items that's allowable under the
therapeutic they come up with crohn's
disease
so then they come to me as an already
employee
and say Hey you know I have Crohn's
disease I've been provided with a
therapeutic cannabis use
card
and I want the ability to
to do this to utilize it now x 3 26x3
actually allows the individual
to
it requires them to get written
permission from the property owner
to use their barability therapeutic
qualifying patient may use cannabis on
privately owned property only with the
written permission of the property owner
so is that one of the written
permissions that you you've talked about
um
I I have I have copies of this if anyone
wants to read along yeah does that would
that be helpful he's even reading it off
so Mr chairman you don't mind if I go
through this and kind of my thought
process of going through this and trying
to understand real life situations
because I
um
I want to be able to break down an
existing employee and a new employee
and then the existing employee or and
then the the breakdown the part about
not being able to terminate versus not
being able to ask when it comes to the
hiring position okay so those are the
the things I'm looking at
so
um
in order to utilize it they must have
written permission
or the property owner
or if they're a tenant
um
allow qualifications to smoke cannabis
on rental property one of the things
that I'd like to talk about as we maybe
clean things up since we now have a lot
of edibles
should it be appropriate to add
something to this to the current law
about
ingesting Edibles because not everyone
gets I mean is therapeutic cannabis only
smokable marijuana in the state of New
Hampshire no therapeutic cannabis comes
with a variety of routes of
administration inhalable
products combustion or non-combustion
tinctures which are you know oil that's
you know that you put in your mouth
topicals like solves Edibles beverages
Etc so suppositories
okay didn't know about that okay so just
off the top of my head should should you
know right now it basically says to
allow a qualifying Pages for cannabis on
rented property if smoking on the
property violates at least is there
anything that needs to be updated here
in your opinion that's going to
potentially even if we don't allow
anything other than even if we don't
agree to any other parts of the current
bill
should there be any changes made to
include some of these other mechanisms
to get permission to I look I look at
paragraph one differently I look at
paragraph one as um
if where you live you know um if you're
releasing property where you live
um you know when we're talking about
employ employer employee you know the
the important sections are are I I would
I would redirect to uh
respectfully to paragraph two
um paragraph two
a two nothing in this chapter she'll
exempt any person from arrest or
prosecution
for being under the influence of
cannabis while in his or her place of
employment without the written
permission of the employer
okay period okay to me that gives the
employer
absolute control
or or the ability to determine that an
employee
cannot be under the influence
at the place of employment without the
employer's written permission
regardless of impairment Under the
Influence is not impairment
it's it's it's a it is arguably a
different standard
so
all the all the cases all the all the
case studies that I'm hearing from
people who have concerns
um
to me don't
they don't I don't hear how the employer
is disadvantaged
because under the amen of the the
solely because there is a positive drug
test
there has to be some other Factor
you know uh at play and an employer can
come up with any number of factors like
the example that you provided uh last uh
a couple weeks ago was
um
my employee got into an accident and
then the company's policy is a mandatory
drug test
therapeutic cannabis patient comes back
positive as you would expect
but the positive drug test is not is not
the only Factor the factor is he was in
an accident
so the person gets fired
due to being in an accident an
uncomfortable vehicle on company time
and it's
not an issue of the fact that he had a
positive drug test it was there's two
factors accident and a positive drug
test
he can be terminated and I'm not a I'm
not a labor attorney and I'm not an
arbitrator and I'm not I'm not familiar
with these cases but to me it seems you
know it seems fairly straightforward
um that there needs to be something else
involved and what this this is a modest
bill in my opinion that just says that
you know in in that case where that
where where it can't where a candidate
for employment is determined to be the
best possible candidate out of all
but you have to take a drug test and you
come back positive and you're
and your therapeutic cannabis patient
yeah you've already been determined to
be the best possible candidate of all
the candidates that applied but yes the
bill would say you still have to hire
them but it doesn't mean that the
employer needs to give that person
permission
to possess cannabis at the workplace
to be under the influence of cannabis at
the workplace and it certainly doesn't
let them be impaired
doesn't let them Drive doesn't let them
operate heavy machinery but that person
has already been determined to be the
best possible candidate
and when we have a a a a drug test that
just yes of course I'm going to fail
that THC blood uh blood blood test
that should not be the reason why the
bill proposes the idea that that should
not be the sole Factor
for not hiring that person
once that person is hired the employer
has
any number of options
in front of them
to limit their use and to fire them if
they
do anything but solely
have a positive drug test
which they always which they will always
there's got to be some other Factor so I
don't representative infantine I don't
mean to interrupt but
um you know so I or or you know go off
on on a tangent but you know so I look
at I look at 2A 2.
you can't be under the influence
um
then you go under uh Roman 2
d
2.
nothing in this chapter shall exempt a
person from a rest or prosecution
for the possession of cannabis
in a place of employment without the
written permission of the employer so
you can't use it while you're at work
you can't possess it while at work
without the permission of the of your
employer
and then if you go down to
Roman 3 C nothing in this chapter shall
be construed to require
any accommodation of the therapeutic use
of cannabis on the property or premises
of any place of employment
along with other places this chapter
shall in no way limit an employer's
ability to discipline an employee for
ingesting cannabis in the workplace or
for working while under the influence of
cannabis
to me this is a very modest Bill and it
patients on using therapeutic cannabis
that that product
should be treated like
there's no other medication
that has the same standard
as what's already in the law
no one is required to disclose their
opiate use or their benzodiazepine use
or any other medication
if you're on the therapeutic cannabis
program you must disclose that if you're
doing that if you're if you're engaging
in that activity taking your medicine
while at work
so when when we when we when we think
about when we think about these cases
these examples that we we started to go
down the road on and all the examples
that have been that have been imagined
you know
I don't see this I I don't see anything
that would limit an employer's ability
to discipline an employee because every
other case that you've mentioned has
another factor involved
all this bill does is say that
that pre-screening drug test or that
pre-employment drug test if you're a
therapeutic cannabis patient
and they've already been selected as the
best candidate possible amongst all the
people who've been who've applied
you got to hire them because they're the
best
and they have a medical condition
and their doctor has said using
therapeutic cannabis is the best way to
only representative so I wasn't trying
to find testimony no I'm sorry it's good
to have this conversation open
conversation so you're fine
representative
thank you Mr chairman I know I'm not
part of this committee so I appreciate
the Indulgence
um using your example Mr Holt with the
prospective employer employee does not
notify the employer that they are on the
medical marijuana plan
and the employer says you come back
positive we're not going to hire you
and now all of a sudden you pull out
your card is that actionable against the
employer
if I were a if I were a therapeutic
cannabis patient and I was very
interested in having that job
and this law was this this bill passes
in its law
it would be in my interest to disclose
that
um at
at some point around the time when I
learned that there's a mandatory drug
test by the way I will come back
positive
for THC because I'm a therapeutic
cannabis patient
um
is it actionable I mean these are these
are legal terms that and I'm not an
attorney I I would argue that virtually
anything is actionable I mean we were
you know I work for the state I mean any
adverse action that the Department of
Health and Human Services makes to any
of our clients is appealable so if your
question is
is it everything's actionable
people people can people can bring
lawsuits for for any perceived grievance
followers so if this law passes what
would be the um
employers rights under this he would
have no he would have no rights because
the employee has that card now he has to
hire him even though
he failed the drug test
without prior knowledge
so he would have to hire this employee
regardless
I don't know what other rights employee
employers have under other law that
might come to bear
so I I I can't say that
they are required to hire but the the
scenario that's been described is of all
the candidates this candidate is
determined to be the best
they fail the drug test and they show a
cannabis card under this bill
absent my knowledge of any other
labor law
it is possible that they
would be subject to a grievance if they
chose to not hire the person contrary
to this bill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
the problem may have and hopefully you
can maybe clarify some stuff for me
um
I knew this guy once that smoked quite a
bit apart
and uh when they go to work he was kind
of a space shot
you know
um couldn't be trusted to to do uh
calculations correctly uh you know a cut
a board correctly in a construction site
or whatever and uh
the the problem I have is if he has a
card
the employer is his hands are tied he
can't say uh you know you're a lousy
employee but it's but I've got this card
um if uh if a construction worker
is not able to use it his or her tools
properly like a like a like a saw or a
tape measure and is cutting pieces of
wood improperly
then as an employer
don't you think you have the right to
discipline that employee for poor work
performance
absolutely that's what that's what I'm
worried about here and so and so the
card is irrelevant
that person can be disciplined or
terminated
based on the poor work performance no
this employer hasn't as an experience
with with somebody with a cannabis card
and somebody else comes along
and they want to be hired for this job
and they've got all the qualifications
but he's got this bad taste in his mouth
maybe not only one but two or three or
four other employees and to take that
that right to say
I'm not going down that road again
um is uh
I I can't we've got to take that out as
the employer as a as a hiring manager
myself
who deals with you know
many resumes for every position that I
hire for
it it seems it it doesn't seem like a
realistic
um shackle
um to not be able to find another reason
not to hire an individual
there's there's always someone who is
better at something
I guess what I'm trying to say is uh you
know a a small home improvement company
and in the end a lot of times I hired
people on gut instinct
do you do a mandatory drug test
at times I did
you know depending on the position so
sometimes sometimes you did and
sometimes you didn't yeah okay
um depending on the position
but would have boiled down to a lot of
times was gut instinct and I don't want
to take that away from an employer to
to be able to say no there's something
that just doesn't fit here how does this
bill take away an employer's ability to
hire based on gut instinct
well his gut instinct on pass on past uh
past experience with others
um you know I did this uh
that's a that that was part of the
hiring process with me that gut instinct
you know and it was it was based on past
the business I mean this but exact this
bill does not talk about this bill
doesn't address gut instincts this bill
says that if you
this bill says that just because you
have a card mm-hmm
you can't be
denied employment or terminated and it
says just because you have a
positive test for THC you can't be
denied employment or terminated it
doesn't say that any other reason you
can be terminated or not hired for
and what it does say is just because an
employer has had a bad bad experience
with somebody
um or somebody else that uh you know
maybe maybe has a cannabis cotton they
smoke a few bones before they come to
work and you can't prove it
you know I'd be real hesitant myself
okay and I don't want that red that that
right taken away okay as an employer I
think you I I don't think this bill
takes away and of course employers
rights in that regard because there are
other reasons why someone can be not not
hired or uh can be terminated um poor
work performance
um I mean if you if you smoke a bone
before work your clothes will smell of
you
you're not if you don't have your
employer's written permission to possess
cannabis at the workplace if you smell
like cannabis it sounds to me like you
had the the the law says they you can be
arrested for that
not just not hired the law establishes
that you can be arrested if you show up
on a work at a workplace with cannabis
in your pocket or being under the
influence of it yeah I could see
somebody using Febreze on their clothes
represent them from
um all right so
I'm gonna move away a little bit from
that conversation
um
and what I'd like to know is in the
amendment it says that the section shall
not apply in cases where this limitation
conflicts with the employer's
obligations under federal law or
regulations or to fulfill a federal
contract or licensing obligations it's
lines 13 and 14 on the amendment
um do we have a list of what those
positions are or employers are that
would qualify under that and giving this
licensing obligation piece with the
changes that the governor is proposing
in our state licensure
um how is that going to be affected I
guess I would like to learn a little bit
more about that
and um
my other comment on this is to move away
a little bit from the hiring practice
I understand the what what
representative was saying again about
the votes on the house floor and what
the likely votes may be on this as well
um I would feel
a little bit more comfortable if we
removed the part about denying
employment
um you know I guess that would be an
area that I could be
flexible on
the other part of it I'm hearing what's
being said as far as soleon although you
know I would argue the the argument of
the accident if somebody had an accident
and they tested positive for cannabis
use and somebody had an accident who
didn't test positive for cannabis use
and that person was not terminated but
the one who was tested positive for
cannabis use I think they would have a
hard time explaining that they
terminated them because they had an
accident
and again I'm sensitive to the fact that
our law enforcement
cannot test for the level of intoxic
intoxication on cannabis use so when an
accident happens it becomes a he said
she said because there's no test that
can provide them with information such
as what they have with um alcohol
so
I would like to see a list if I could on
the limitations that they're saying here
under the obligations of federal law
regulations in the federal Contracting
licensing
and I would like to talk further about
my understanding is that um the a
document was shared that was created by
the marijuana policy project which has a
uh a listing of every State's position
on uh therapeutic on medical marijuana
therapeutic cannabis and their and their
projections and or protections and
restrictions
um in that document there are uh
I I have not digested and internalized
all 50 states
um policies
um and so I can't give you that list but
I believe the the that document is
certainly a good starting place
um I did a quick Google search before I
came here and there's the there's a
federal Omnibus Transportation Act
um that identifies uh some
um ACLU has documentation on on uh
testing standards in different states
um there's a law passed in the 80s uh
that prohibit illiter drug use of
federal employees you know it's on the
books there's there's plenty of
information out there you know
um that that has that has those has has
an explanation of the language that is
in the amendment the the language and
the amendment is is a catch-all that
that all of those other documents
federal law can be hung upon without
listing each single uh
employment category
um but I I am not prepared to give you a
list of everything that falls under that
because I simply don't know
um and absent any absent you know any
any
yeah absolutely absent like a a a
commitment to like this if we come up
with a list this will be palatable to
move forward I mean it's it's hard to
dedicate that time of time as someone
who's as a department employee where the
department doesn't have a position on
this bill I'm sorry I think you
misunderstood I wasn't necessarily
asking it from you I was asking it more
from our study so if it has to go to our
research and if that does end up with
you then I understand what you're saying
so I apologize for that um if but the
email you spoke of that just came in two
minutes before we started so I have not
had a chance to go through all of the
states to read all of that data so that
that came in um before this meeting so
we need some time I think to read that
email and digest the information in
there can an employer not hire someone
if the mandatory drug tests you know
pre-employment drugs test comes back is
positive for opiates
and those opiates are being prescribed
by a doctor can can somebody can can an
employer
not hire that person because they are
prescribed an opiate and they test
positive for opiates
to my understanding and the decisions
that were made in the business that I
was in was yes they could choose not to
hire for that they could have the
conversation they could find out what's
going on we were in HVAC company so
there was a lot of roof work crane work
um high risk work electrical work so not
to mention the amount of vehicles that
we operated so um they may have made
okay thank you Mr chairman I'm just
curious if somebody has an answer to
this question I know there's we talk
about the impairment and if there's an
accident
somebody gets tested for cannabis use
most times it's going to be a urine test
if somebody's involved in an accident
um
police departments
allowed to test
for take a blood sample
and
and if they can test blood sample
can cannabis be picked up the amount of
cannabis that's in somebody's system be
picked up in a blood test do you do you
know if that
happens if it's
the the level of cannabis the level of
THC
is detectable
in a person's body through a blood test
so if somebody's involved in an accident
causing Serious injury
most likely
I wouldn't say most likely it it's
possible that a blood test could be done
to see how much THC is in that system
absolutely that as we know the difficult
part with that is that
the level of THC in someone's blood is
not necessarily indicative of impairment
like a level of alcohol in the blood is
and so we have chronic users who are
using every night
every day
never doing it during the day they will
not be impaired but their blood will
come back with a very high level
some states have chosen to establish an
arbitrary level of THC in the blood as
something over which
you'll be deemed impaired regardless of
your actual impairment some states have
done this
it's and some states have done this and
then you know been sued uh successfully
and and those laws have determined to be
someone that's going to consume a five
milligram gummy at nine o'clock at night
will not be impaired when they go to
work the next morning that's correct
versus that person that may as
representative love said smokes a bone
if they smoke the entire joint that
could be anywhere from
let's say 20 THC to 26 possibly even 30
percent THC
um at nine o'clock at night they consume
that entire
joint
um
they're still most likely not going to
be impaired the next morning eight hours
later they will not be in they'll have a
positive test based upon the fact that
it stays in it's going to stay in your
system a lot longer in both those cases
and I think that's part of the what I'm
hearing here is you know we're worried
about the impairment again I truly
believe that the people that are on the
therapeutic cannabis that are looking
for employment are not going to be your
people that are really going out
um and going to
smoke that
marijuana
um that has 26 THC and expect somebody
at work not to notice that I don't see
that as being a problem
um right they might take 2.5 milligrams
of a tincture in the morning before work
not bring it hopefully it lasts all day
you know and not be impaired at all not
feel impairment you know uh under the
law would they be under the influence
you know
probably and when we say and just
correct me if I'm wrong here under the
influence doesn't necessarily is it
there are difference between under the
influence and impairment because if
you're impaired you obviously have a
high level sort of like alcohol correct
I mean they're saying what is it point
zero eight is you can I mean you can you
can be arrested for being intoxicated
even if your blood comes back at under
0.08 I mean if you if you just if you
display other
um other other signs of impairment you
know you don't you know you're still you
know you can be arrested detained and
prosecuted for you know Reckless
Behavior even though you're coming back
under 0.08 yeah and and I my whole
concern here is that you know I don't
want to push this off because I truly
I truly believe in a therapeutic
cannabis program
um
I think people that have been around for
a while understand where we've gone with
opioids I think everybody understands
the you know the problems we've had with
it
um and you know I think therapeutic
cannabis program has really helped I
know several people that do it
um and it's helped them as
representative infantig said so
I'm just concerned that we're
I might I want to move something forward
I want us to get off the fixation of
um this impairment thing because again I
truly believe that people that are using
at night
um it's not going to be bothersome to
the employers
um the next day now again
I think we all agree that
somebody that shows up and may have
taken a 10 milligram you know at work I
there are signs that people are going to
be aware of that somebody that's under
the impairment of marijuana I mean
I believe that there's
uh police officers are trained to you
know
um they can pull you know they can see
that drugs recognition experts yeah okay
so and that's all I'm saying I I want to
move something forward I I like it
um I think it's something that's needed
I understand the concerns but I think we
really have to try to get away from the
fixation on this impairment part of it
because I don't again I'm going to give
those people that have therapeutic
cannabis Cottage the benefit of the
doubt that they are not trying to do it
so that they can abuse it at work I'm
giving them the benefit of the doubt
that they really want this to help their
medical condition
um they do it at night
not everybody's going to do that I
understand that we're not you know and
we can't Safeguard everybody but I truly
believe that the majority of these
people look at it as something that you
know was helping them
um and I think it's something that we
should move forward so with that Mr
chairman thank you for indulging me
thank you representative um one thing I
would like to bring up when we were
when the debates were going on was last
week for the the uh legalizing marijuana
I believe was representative Roy
uh testified about the law enforcement
in his committee how they said there is
no way of telling whether the you know
spoke to Joint last night or that the
higher than the Georgia Pine right now
uh there's no
no uh therapeutic not therapy I would
say no uh no no medical proof that uh so
you know we've got a problem there uh
that if
if somehow they ever came up with a test
that works it'd be uh the answer to all
of this
now and I'll just say to and it's I
think we have to trust people that's I
mean it's you know when something like
this is in place
um I think it's in place I think that
programs in place for a reason
um and again I'll keep reiterating I
truly don't believe that
and I'm not speaking for everybody but I
truly believe that the majority of these
people are not abusing um
and I understand like we've talked about
this we can say it a thousand times and
yes absolutely they're going to pass
they're going to fail a drug test
there's no doubt about it but it doesn't
mean they're abusing
um the program
if I might I just I might just remind
the the
subcommittee that their New Hampshire
does have case law
um that information was shared with all
of you as well
um that establishes or uh uh establishes
a requirement on the part of an employer
um to
consider an accommodation under the AGA
um that cannabis in a state where it's
legal is a legitimate therapy and an
employer must accommodate or at least
consider an accommodation where
appropriate so we are we already have
case law you know that protects people
the point of this bill is to allow
individuals who are on the program to
not have to sue their employer at Great
or potential employer at Great cost to
them
for the protection that the courts have
already given them
and to force their employers to to to
take this to take this seriously that
this is it is legal in the state
it's a medication
authorized by a medical provider
like any other medication
case law says employers have to consider
that
but the only recourse for patients
senator valgolini
thank you again Mr chairman
because I think you're using
interchangeably with the
cannabis program and prescribed
medications
cannabis as
a medication or as a therapy
the therapeutic cannabis law does not
use the it is it is intentionally not
medical marijuana
there is no prescription like for other
medications
and the reason for these
policy choices that the New Hampshire
legislature made is because it's
federally illegal
and a schedule 1 substance cannot be
prescribed
however
it is
used like a medication
the point of this of this law is to
relieve symptoms of certain medical
conditions
that that you've been that a patient has
been diagnosed with
so
what we say in the in the department
when we talk about this program to
people we call this an alternative
therapy
this is therapeutic cannabis it's not a
prescription
it's not a medication because it cannot
um I pointed out a provision of law I
think at the last session uh that said
that the use of therapeutic cannabis
um with regard to Medical Care shall be
considered the equivalent of a
prescribed medication
um
126x colon 2 Roman 7.
qualifying patients authorized use of
cannabis in accordance with this chapter
shall be considered to be the equivalent
of the authorized use of any other
medication used at the direction of a
provider and shall not constitute use of
an illicit substance
um so
I'm not gonna I'm not going to Define
what a medication is if if that is
defined in law so be it
um but
I think my answer talks about you know
from what I'm hearing in the interview
and the discussion has been I don't
think there's a question about the
program I think it's a question about
how to dovetail this into labor law
and
sometimes we ask a lot of questions to
make sure that we have the right answers
when regular people read this and say
how come I can't do this or why are you
I'm not allowing us to do this we want
to be able to have those answers and or
make this clear enough that there's no
ambiguity ambiguity and ambiguous
language that the department would now
have to clarify
um based upon what this law says the
Department of Labor Department of Labor
um well I mean the Department of Labor I
mean every executive agency has rule
making Authority with regard to
interpreting and making more clear
statutes that is correct I just want to
make sure that we're on the same
direction because they might interpret
it a completely different way or an
employment attorney May interpret it a
completely different way which adds
additional costs to the employer should
they be sued under this law
so we're trying to I'm sorry yeah I I
understand the only point the point that
I was trying to make as the last point
that I was you know trying to remind the
subcommittee of is that there is case
law that that that does something
similar
um but patients don't have access to
don't have access to that remedy if they
don't have any money
and if they don't have a job they
certainly don't have money to pay for an
attorney to protect them from you know
from uh
from actions
um that are already codified in case law
you know that's all so there's there's
cost on both you know there's cost on
both on both uh
uh
sides
um I I shared with representative
infantine I don't know if he shared it
with you but you know just a question
was asked last time but like how many
people are we talking about I don't know
if he shared that information with you
um you know
um we do have a voluntary survey
question you know are you basically are
you employed there are 3 300
people out of the 14 000 that have said
that they're currently employee of the
part-time you know 43 but only about
half of the people answered the question
58 of respondents right 58 of the
population answer the question right so
basically there's there's a whole chunk
of people who we don't know if we apply
the 43 who did or the 43 of the 58 who
answered 43 said they did if we just
apply that 43 to the total amount we've
got 5 800 people in the state that are
employed that are on the Cannabis
program
thank you
Mr Holt can you tell me again what
what's your position
um with the state
I'm a uh I am a section administrator
within the division of Public Health
Services and I oversee two programs
um one is the therapeutic cannabis
program and the other is the
prescription drug monitoring program
so work for the division of yeah public
health irct2 programs section
administrator
representative Sullivan I guess um I
meant to the point where I'd like to
make a suggestion as to how we might
move forward
um
uh be willing to
suggest a an adjustment to this removing
the shell deny employment
the amendment
and it would you know provide some
protection to those who are employed
against
um
discipline or termination
um and uh and frankly I think depending
on how a legal opinion might work out
the people who weren't hired might still
have a recourse in court
but basically if
if making that adjustment would uh
satisfy the subcommittee I would be
willing to make the adjustment
and then based on that make a ought to
pass recommendation back to the
committee what do we think
I think that's a start
um the the cave outs for different
occupations would certainly have to be
in it and then we can start talking for
not to pass some
there's a carve out already based on the
if if I might I I would I would I would
recommend that you speak with an
attorney about that uh that position
because
um my non-attorney belief is that
that may reduce the protections already
afforded through case law what would
Reduce by by remu by removing what
you're suggesting to remove and that is
the the protection from you know denial
of employment based solely on a a test
that that may that may REM
that may remove or lessen the
protections that have already been
established you know under case law
because that was the case this person
was denied the case person was denied
employment based on you know a test
um so I would just caution I would call
I would just caution that you know
uh that that that that that effort May
reduce current uh rights that patients
have under the the case law
a lawyer may want to uh uh provide an
opinion on that before you move forward
if we're talking about the same case uh
would be uh Mr Payne against right away
pain B right away correct uh he's a
former employer employee he says so he
was employed by them
so that's not my recollection of the
case so I'm reading from a former
employee sued right away for failing to
make reasonable accommodations okay so
he's if he was awesome he was already
thank you
I guess I'd uh
either make a make a suggestion that we
we take a look at what occupations uh we
should have out of this you know there
are federal protections for truck
drivers and what have you uh you know
there's there's other things that um you
know construction type things that uh
you know we should we should be
taking out of this
but um and there's there'll be a lot of
occupations that will will fit under it
but um
you know uh
I don't know if we want to go with any
you know individual occupations or just
a a blanket statement any any occupation
that may involve the health and safety
of others um and I I think the advice we
got at the outset was that that type of
language was too broad too vague and
would not work particularly well because
you could suggest that any employment
might be in that category that that's
that's why initially they said you know
don't use this don't don't use a
give us time to look over this email it
came in this morning
um give me a little bit more time to
look at the exclusions I still have
issue with bus drivers so and how it
relates to schools schools are drug-free
zone so I wanna kind of bring that piece
into my head as an employer are they
part of the excluded process or the
trust plus drivers part of the excluded
process
um and but and I guess the question
there would be do they have a CDL
license I think
in which case they are
there are uh
yeah
yeah there are the the handicapped vans
that they have to school school kids uh
you just need a regular driver's license
for that
um yeah yes you know so it's not a CDL
so yeah so uh but uh maybe
go all of us go home and write out a
list of carve outs and and present them
and we'll do another meeting like uh
I know the
um the Chairman's intention is to uh
exec this on the 16th
um so anything we do needs to take that
into uh consideration so we would need
to
we have our work finished by
Wednesday the 8th
by three o'clock so that it can go into
the calendar as an exec
question
I'm fine with that before the eighth
if I may Mr chairman sure
um I would also like to for the comedian
I hate to say it to look at
workman's compensation and liability
insurance because if
an employee does comes to work for them
that doesn't have that card gets injured
outside of work comes back with that
card
is the employer now can't terminate or
deny or take this planning reaction but
may lose their insurance coverage
because of that because the insurance
company requires a certain standard or
they work when it's comp requires a
certain standard
this would tie the hands of the employer
saying okay well I can't terminate you
now I have to go out and find all new
coverages for Car Insurance liability
insurance truck insurance workman's
compensation I mean you can go on and on
and on
and what caused it and what if they
can't be insured because of their line
of work that doesn't fall under the
federal
limits or even State limits I would just
like to clarify that thank you Mr
chairman
you know with all the uh
all the things that you know we brought
up with whether it's be uh votes or
um ad Entertainer
a motion to retain this this bill just
representative thank you Mr chairman I
also want to make the chairman aware
that there is a member of honorable
okay I I I I I was unaware of being a
new member of the committee but uh do
you have any input
hi
that's right
okay uh do we have any extra details do
you also have the amended version no I
don't if that was actually going to be a
question
I'll tell you what I'll lend you mine
okay
he's got one
yeah
okay for those of us who don't know you
uh but just stay in it I apologize I was
immigroman attorney with the New
Hampshire Department of Labor
um so there is
there is a bit of a change where you
have on Roman numeral one and that was
going to be my question because on the
original bill it said solely because the
individual is a qualified patient of the
New Hampshire therapeutic cannabis
program under RSA 126x and and that was
the key to me
because that would require both of those
elements to be met in order to
talk about hiring firing processes so
that was definitely altered in here so I
just want to take a look if it's okay
foreign
okay so my understanding is standing in
the amendment is it's really just broken
down a little bit better instead of
um so that took care of one of my
questions
I guess uh you know um the idea of
having carve outs uh how
what would you what would you have to
what kind of input could you give us on
that well obviously the Department of
Labor does not take a position on this
particular bill and the general
consensus is is whatever this committee
comes up with and presents and if it's
made law
we will understand the intent because we
have been listening and we will
administer it as we have interpreted the
statute
um
as far as suggestions on carve outs I
would look at 126 x and make sure that
there's not going to be any
inconsistencies between whatever this
bill ends up being and what's in 126x
126x has some protections for employers
as far as the hiring and the firing but
they have to sign that and I believe
that the representative from dhsh Mr
Holt even described it there has to be
something that has to be signed by the
employer that they're accepting the fact
that this employee has a therapeutic
cannabis card as well as will likely
have a positive drug test
um if that statute says and I don't have
it in front of me but if that statute
says as representative infantine said
that
the employer does not have to sign
that's a protection that the employer
that the Department of Labor would
interpret the employer having as okay
I don't believe that this is the best
candidate for this job because of
a b and c but including being on
therapeutic cannabis I was listening to
some concerns about part of the reason
why it was removed from the original
Bill language talking about it being too
broad about if for safety concerns this
would not apply and and that being too
broad I understand that
um
I think the interpretation based upon
the statute of Labor looking at this
would be looking at specific jobs which
goes to the carve outs that you were
talking about
my recommendation would be to make sure
that if you do intend to put in carve
outs be careful that you don't specify
everything down to the letter so that
somebody comes in and says okay well you
said a b and c but you didn't say d so
that doesn't count
and I don't know how there it can be
done
um but these are concerns that we would
be looking at if a case were to come
into the Department of Labor whether it
be under workers comp or whether it be
under wage an hour
um where we would have to try to
interpret
both with 126x as well as under the
protections under wage an hour under
all the different sections under 281a
for the workers comp statute so
I would
I guess my recommendation on that would
be just to
keep that in mind as you're looking at
particular carve outs
cdl's obviously police fire EMT
some of them seem obvious
but
if you if you if you make it too finite
um
representative
um just want to be clear about
126x3
as I understand it you can't
be in possession of cannabis on the job
without assigned permission
you can't be under the influence of
cannabis on the job without signing
permission
um
but I don't believe
you cannot be under the influence
however you might test positive for
cannabis or for THC
so it seems that if
if you're one of these nighttime users
and you only take it before you go to
sleep and you're no longer under the
influence in the morning then you can go
to work you have nothing signed by the
employer because you're not bringing it
to work with you you're not under the
influence at work but you would still be
subject to a positive test
um so you have not
um uh
the employer can't uh choose not to
employ you
um or can't discipline or terminate you
um for being under the influence or
being in possession because you were
none of the above you simply tested
positive
by interpreting that correctly I see Mr
Holtz nodding his head so I'm continuing
today I would have I would like to be
able to do that to give you a complete
answer on that but I can take it to a
different level and look at it from the
perspective of any other substance
if you're taking some form of an opiate
and that opiate you took at
you know the night time but you're still
feeling the effects because maybe you're
not in a continuous opiate user you're
still feeling the effects but you're not
necessarily Under the Influence or
you're not impaired if you drink alcohol
all weekend long and you showed up for
work on Monday
you may have the appearance of someone
who drank all weekend long but you may
not be under the influence or impaired
um
so
I think that we can look at
cannabis in that suggest and I I would
have to look at some of the statue too
where it talks about you can't prescribe
the Cannabis as opposed to calling it a
medication I believe there was a request
as far as a definition between
medication it was it was made very clear
to me by my doctor that you are not
getting a prescription from me you were
simply getting
um I'm going to fill out the form to
allow you to have the card and and
that's the last interaction you have
with the doctor
they simply
um you know give you the authorization
get the card
um but I guess my
I understood for Mr Holt that there's a
difference between impairment and being
under the influence
um and impairment is as we've discussed
uh
somewhat difficult to track but not
impossible I would say being under the
influence is probably thoroughly
impossible to detect because you
basically you
um
you've still got THC in your system but
it's not no longer doing anything
because it's you just got the uh
positive test but essentially the
nighttime user I from what I understand
is generally deemed to be no longer
Under the Influence when they go to work
the next day
um and um
so I I guess I was just trying to
clarify and maybe I need to give you a
chance to review but um it seems like a
card holder
cannabis therapeutic cannabis user or a
patient
um
can you get nothing it can can carry on
with their life without having their
employer sign anything
because they're neither Under the
Influence nor in the possession of
cannabis on the job
so I don't believe
as you stated a few a little while ago
that that could be a reason for an
employer to either fire or not hire
um
because basically if the person it
doesn't fit either of those two
circumstances
um there's no need for the employer to
sign anything
I think the biggest difficulty that
comes out of that and I think it's been
mentioned before is trying to make that
determination as to whether or not they
are under the influence or they are
impaired from being able to do their job
in any way
um being under the influence can simply
mean uh for somebody who takes
painkillers you're under the influence
of it because it's easing your pain so
obviously it's still working
but are you impaired by it and that's
that's the difference that would be
presented at a hearing
um and and address causal issues as to
whether or not any particular in looking
at a workers comp case whether a
particular injury was actually caused by
an impairment or was just caused by
uh employee mistake or you know just a
simple accident
um
I think that
that is something that a hearing officer
would have to take in evidence for
um there may be medical evidence or it
may just be observational evidence
and that comes down to you have field
sobriety tests that law enforcement is
able to use to determine if someone is
under the influence or impaired while
they're driving but then you have
certain people who may have a higher
tolerance level who may not appear
impaired at all but yet they are when it
comes to different types of jobs so I
think trying to make that determination
is the hardest part of all of this
to be able to factor that into in the
language
in your opinion
if somebody is uh using therapeutic
cannabis
and you mentioned well let me back up
when you mentioned how somebody using
opioids could come to work and be in a
fog okay possibly making mistakes and if
somebody using therapeutic mechanists is
if this became law would the employer be
prohibited from saying I can't use you
anymore I can't use you in this state I
can't you know you you're you know you
might not be impaired but you're
certainly not doing a very good job
would that um would that prohibit the
employer from laying off until the
condition improves or possibly firing
first I would point out again let's make
sure that there's no inconsistency
between the bill that you're going to
present and 126x but that being said
I think that the Department of Labor
would look at the employer having the
argument that you this employee is no
longer
um safe in the environment safe with
other employees safe with the activities
of the specific job tasks that he or she
has
would they have an argument I think
that's going to end up going to an
employment lawyer and most likely a
civil case if that person is terminated
as far as the Department of Labor is
concerned
the way it would come into play in a lot
of circumstances would be in a workers
compensation case where somebody let's
say is under a specific prescription for
a painkiller an opiate
if they're taking it as that it is
prescribed which in most cases it's a
it's a PRN or an as needed type of a
prescription if they're taking it as
prescribed and the employer is accepting
the fact that yes we can go ahead and
accommodate what we need to do we're
just going to keep you away from things
where safety is an issue
then the employer has accepted that and
underneath the statute if the employer
knows that that person is under the
influence that can't be a defense to
terminate them or to refuse any benefits
but what
what the employer's obligation at that
point in times make sure not only that
an employee is safe and the employees
working with that person are safe the
same thing would be applied or should be
applied in a situation where there's
therapeutic cannabis
if that employer does not believe that
the use of therapeutic can and they
don't know when they're using it keep
that in mind there because there's no
prescription there's no timeline
and that's a question I have had for a
long time how does that work
um but if the employer sees that there
is an issue with safety
that employer has an argument
how strong that is will depend on
unemployment lawyer but that employer
would have an argument that that person
was no longer the best person for this
job not because he was Ill not under the
Ada but because the use of whatever
substance
how how about um in a position where uh
say for instance uh you handle a lot of
money you're making a lot of mistakes
um you know and you're you have one of
these cards uh what rights does the
employer have
well in that particular case you're not
dealing with a safety issue you're
dealing with a lot of mistakes which
would be underneath the regular laws of
at-will employment now it has nothing to
do with you know how do you make an
accommodation for a teller not being
able to count because he or she is on
Med uh excuse me therapeutic cannabis
um so then you have the ability to
terminate someone for cause and cause
would be no longer being able to perform
the tasks of the job that you were hired
for so they wouldn't be able to just use
this card as an excuse and you can't
fire me is what I'm saying would they of
course everybody tries to do whatever
they need to do
um how it would pan out in a hearing
would determine the evidence presented
to a hearing officer and have a hearing
officer make that decision and possibly
go up to an appeal panel from there
probably have another meeting I know the
universe
I heard you motion or are you looking to
retain but I would say that maybe we
meet one more time before we make the
motion I mean I know next week we get I
to meet you on either Monday or Tuesday
and if we can't come to any consensus I
would recommend that you know we move
forward with something then
mm-hmm
I I would propose
somewhere in the vicinity of 2 10 a.m on
Tuesday
maybe not that works for me but doesn't
wow why do you guys don't think they're
not going to ask the email sure
any information you can get
thank you again Mama
um the question I have is and you
reference it to uh workplace
compensation was if workman's
compensation determines through their
initial
their initial triage of the accident
that they have I see what you're saying
yeah well they have 48 hours to you know
or however long it it takes for them to
approve a claim and they come back and
say okay well this person tested
positive for this this and this we're
not going to honor this claim is the
employer now
on the hook for all of the
some of the injuries no
the reason for that is because uh the
carrier has up to 21 days to issue a
denial in a workers compensation case
and I've seen it in several occasions
even when I was workers comp defense
attorney outside of the Department of
Labor where a carrier will deny if there
is a positive test for anything it
doesn't matter if it's an illicit drug
or if it's a prescribed drug they'll
deny it
um the primary basis is usually because
the assumption is that that impaired
them from doing their job and they
didn't let their employer know or or
their employer wasn't given an option to
not allow them to do that job so they
have up to 21 days to issue a denial
but in New Hampshire we also have the
concept underneath 281a of payment
without prejudice so there can be some
payment of medical
benefits initial treatments
like going to one of the smaller
satellite I guess you would call a
medical offices and things like that
there's a way that they can be paid by
the carrier and later denied as no
longer being related pursuant to further
investigation
until the Department of Labor issues a
decision
the uh there's two different major
benefits there's Indemnity benefits
which is the disability payments and
then there's the medical benefits if the
Department of Labor issues a decision
that no they were not under the
influence or that they're not allowed to
use that Statute in order to be able to
defend the case
then payment of the indemnity benefits
does have to be made within five days
but is paid by the carrier
as far as the medically stay the medical
pending appeal
if in the end it's all determined that
it's not a compensable injury meaning
that this was not a work-related injury
or that the employer was able to use
intoxication as a defense then it's not
a compensable injury it's not
compensable to be paid by the carrier
and it's not compensable to be paid by
the employer this turns into a personal
injury
so the employee would be able to sue the
employer under a personal injury class
no
of the 281a specifically states that an
employee who has accepted this job has
also accepted the fact that the employer
has Workers Compensation Insurance and
it prevents that employee from either
filing a lawsuit against a co-worker or
filing a lawsuit against the employer so
if an employee claims to have been
injured on the job but it was determined
by a hearing and potentially the appeal
that yes he may have been hurt on the
job but we believe that defensive
intoxication or impairment is a valid
defense therefore it's not a compensable
injury
the employees stuck with his own health
insurance or his own payments
thank you for that
I think important
um so if that follow up Mr chairman yes
just a quick one so if that employee
that is relatively impaired injures A
co-worker
how does that play out okay I like that
one that one's better
so that particular co-worker would have
the ability to file a workers
compensation claim as well because he
was injured on the job he was injured by
another employee but it happens in a lot
of cases as I'm sure that you've all
seen where someone does get injured on
the job and it's because of the
negligence of another employee
strict negligence of course is not a
defense in workers compensation
impairments can be depending upon
certain circumstances if that co-worker
was injured
I think the department of labor would be
looking at the fact that the co-worker
was that person impaired
and that's going to be an argument most
likely by the employer and the carrier
if it's determined that the co-worker
was not impaired or that his injury was
not the result of his own impairment
compensability would likely be found for
did that answer your question it did
a person that caused the accident was
impaired or under the influence would
that play into workman's compensation as
well as the cause for the accident
underneath the statute that allows the
employer to use impairment as a defense
it specifically states that not only
does the employee have to be impaired or
under the influence that employee also
the the injury had to have been caused
by it for an example
um and I can tell you I had a case many
years ago employee was a roofer and
there was a group of roofers that were
working at this particular location
and they were climbing up a ladder with
shingles over their shoulders they get
to the roof they flip the shingles down
they go back down the ladder and start
the process over again
in this particular case a co-worker
actually put up the ladder but the
employer didn't know that at first so
the Assumption was is that the impaired
employee put the ladder up
grab the first load of shingles got
halfway up and the entire ladder toppled
over and he fell about 15 feet straight
to the ground
that case was initially denied because
it was determined that the claimant was
impaired he had been drinking at
lunchtime
it was eventually paid because the
employer knew he had been drinking that
eliminated the defense
the employer should have never obviously
let him back on the job site
so the defense wasn't there but let's
say the employer didn't know that he was
drinking
it's the arguments would be there for
the employer to make then to defend that
but for his drinking he wouldn't have
fallen
so then you have to hit the next step
which is did the actual
alcoholic impairment cause the injury
or did the latter break or you know
something else well it turns out that
one leg of the ladder had been put in
sand and the other leg had been put on
something hard so the ladder in the sand
of course it tipped exactly it tipped
and that's actually what caused him to
fall and when we finally made the
determination it it was another employee
that put up the ladder and mistakenly
put it half on Sand half on hard so I go
back to what the element of proving had
to be
the did the actual impairment of alcohol
can we reverse that
yeah
anything
impaired employee put the ladder in
place and the non-perance way into the
one that was on
Arnold and how that one that is
okay let's start with the non-impaired
employee that was climbing the ladder
and fell
he would file a workers compensation
injury it would obviously go to hearing
there would be evidence presented but
because he was not impaired and was
injured on the job the there's a
likelihood that they will find
compensibility for that particular
person
if the impaired employee who put it up
then there's an argument by the employer
to fire for cause
but then again that goes under
representative I believe what if that
person was a therapeutic card holder and
they just positive for a cannabis can
cannabinoids or metabolites of cannabis
would the employer be able to fire them
up for that
that's part of why we're here today
well it as a former
labor guy
um basically you're not firing the
person for the cannabis use you're
firing them for the negligent placement
of the latter there therefore I mean the
the word solely is in our bill
um and there are not being fired solely
because of the cannabis card they're
being fired because they screwed up and
put the ladder in the wrong place it
would be fired for cause right
one question I have with the insurance
company
be able to say you know we're not paying
because the you know the the employee
that put the latter up uh you know it
was we tested positive
okay uh you know he played a major part
in this accident
um would
wouldn't would an insurance company a
workers comp insurance company be able
to deny a claim with the liability then
I have to start by prefacing that we do
not handle the insurance coverage
aspects I think that's a very good
question to ask the Department of
Insurance to to provide input but using
representative Holcomb's example going
doing the backward one
the
person who is not impaired the person
who actually ended up being injured
because of the impaired person putting
the ladder in the wrong place
the unimpaired person would still have a
workers compensation claim it would
still have to be presented with all of
the evidence to a hearing officer
but they were unimpaired
they were injured on the job
and negligence is not a defense as far
as that particular person is concerned
um there could be arguments and that's
where the evidence comes into play you
can't give a black and white answer to
these but there could be evidence that
comes in that the person who was
climbing the ladder may not have been
impaired but he knew the other person
was
maybe shouldn't have trusted the other
person to place the ladder where he
placed it that could be an argument that
comes in how it's determined from that
point though will determine on what the
hearing officer hears and application to
the current law
yeah I can see an insurance company
coming in
and saying the employer knew of this
medical uh therapeutic cannabis card
okay and
um and he still employed them and this
accident happened and this guy tested
positive and
I can see an insurance company using
that as a defense to not pay
keep in mind one thing
um I I can't remember was in 22 or 21 a
new case came out of the Supreme Court
um and this one is appeal of panaggio
and prior to that the law in New
Hampshire is and I think it still is I
don't think it's been changed yet by the
legislature
um the law was that health insurance
carriers were not required to pay for
medical marijuana and it's a little off
topic but it does come back to the
center
they were not required to pay for
medical marijuana or therapeutic
cannabis
what the Supreme Court in New Hampshire
decided was that workers compensation
insurers are not the same as health care
insurers
and so the the Crux of the decision is
that if ordered
and that's leaves open a whole door of
how that works but if ordered
the workers compensation carrier would
be required to pay if it was ordered by
a reputable doctor and was causally
medically necessary uh for the
particular condition that the person has
my understanding of the law is under
126.6 is they have to have a therapeutic
cannabis card so the the doctor would
have to go through the same form
completion process and that person would
have to have a card and and take it from
there as far as getting the
prescriptions
but
um that law
kind of opened the door to or that that
case kind of open the door to how is
that going to be handled from this point
on
and is it possible because of appeal of
panaggio is it possible that a worker's
compensation insurance carrier would not
be able to deny a claim because someone
was on medical marijuana or therapeutic
cannabis
is that possible I don't know the
answers to those questions
um but I think that they are issues that
can be brought up if a carrier were to
say we're not going to pay because
and then you know the argument on the
other side would be but appeal of
panaggio says you would have to if it
was prescribed in a workers compensation
injury
there's just a lot of things that can
come up in that but I would look to the
Department of Insurance for input as far
as what they would and would not be
willing or have to pay for
thank you
representative abellini
um so through workman's compensation if
the prescribing non-scription if the
doctor recommends that program for them
to get off opioids work bus compensation
would pay anyways because it's it's a
reason to get them back to work or are
you talking about
denying coverage they grew looking in
two different directions yes I think we
I think we are so um if it was a workers
compensation injury if the person and
this happens with um uh severe long-term
chronic injuries where the person is
just in constant pain
they've been on opiates for a very long
time we obviously went through a period
of time several years ago we were trying
to reduce the use of opiates
um in a situation like that a doctor May
recommend
the therapeutic cannabis program
again we're starting out with a workers
comp injury let's start with that Avenue
first
so they go through the process the
application process they get their card
after appeal of panaggio
the workers compensation carrier would
still have the ability to deny under it
was either not causally related not
reasonable or not medically necessary
they go to a hearing it's determined by
the Department of Labor that it meets
all three criteria and it has to meet
all three criteria
also that the prescribing or the
recommending physician
is a
legitimate physician
and that's a concern with the internet
um but then you have the appeal process
in the end if it's determined that it
was causally related to the workers
compensation injury medically necessary
and reasonable and the department made
that determination that would be an
order for the workers compensation
carrier to pay for it
okay and the um having worked on
workman's compensation as you can tell
um could the carriers now decide put in
the caveat saying we're not going to
ensure
for this type of injury
could they do that down the road if this
happens to pass and they know there's
going to be people that could be
impaired working under this
classification when you're saying this
type of vendor you're talking about the
type of injury that may have been caused
by the use of therapeutic cannabis
correct
I think that's going to open the door to
a
a lot of meetings like this
I really do and the reason is from the
Department of Labor standpoint is we'll
get a case in like that and we have to
be able to look at the evidence and
that's what our hearing officers do
so there would have to be a hearing at
least to show
that the therapeutic cannabis was the
cause for them to be able to then turn
around and say okay well under our
policy we don't have to pay but I think
that that probably breaks it into a
whole new hearing usually with the
department of insurance which is I'm
going to say it again I really do
believe that we need you would need to
get the Department of Insurance involved
to make those types of determinations I
think it's I think it's a
a Pandora's Box
and just one final follow-up I know
everybody wants to go
um years ago we worked on workman's
compensation and people before us to
bring more insurers into the state
would this be a legitimate reason for
I can't answer that from a state
knowledge but I would ask you to look at
other states around
Maine has therapeutic cannabis
Massachusetts obviously
it has it open I would look at the other
states around and see how the insurance
carriers have been handling that are
they paying workers compensation are
they denying it is there language that's
being inserted most workers compensation
policies are fairly template
um so
are are they adding any type of
endorsements that say if this then that
I would I would look around to see if
that was going on if that's not going
around in other states then my own
personal opinion would be that it
um
getting back to meeting again I I
suggested 10 I think uh you suggested
on Tuesday
yep one or two that'll work for me
it was great because I can get out early
but she's not part of your committee but
um yeah one or two is fine with me let's
do one o'clock one o'clock on Tuesday
I want to thank the members and the
let's carry on with what we're doing
yeah we close this meeting
okay so that's Tuesday the 7th at 1
right
hopefully if I don't get sucked into the
lifestyle